and show stable as a sumo wrestling Hub
in Tokyo which is known for producing
outstanding Talent hundreds of promising
youth flock to this stable each year
hoping they can make it big however it
is revealed that the places run on a
hierarchical system the junior wrestlers
like our protagonist Jose have to wait
for the seniors to finish eating before
they can have their Meals one of the
seniors is Enga who often mistreats Jose
and another Junior named Shimizu he is
so disgusting that he makes them clean
him after using the restroom Jose always
Rebels against him but Shimizu complies
without saying a word he just takes his
[__] as it were following this we are
shown a flashback which reveals that
Jose had a reputation as a gangster he
used to live with his handicapped father
and absent-minded mother both of whom
were ridden in debt but Jose always
tried his best to save up some money out
of what he made one day a debt collector
as usual arrived at the house to ask for
his money fed up with the repeated
complaints Jose angrily confronted his
mother only to find her sleeping with
another man this infuriated him so much
that he grabbed his mother by her hair
and tossed her outside the room he was
about to assault her further but his
father intervened just in time to
prevent the altercation back in the
present Shimizu is seen cleaning the
sumo wrestling ring before the senior
wrestlers come for practice but Jose who
has a negligent attitude refuses to even
follow the customary practice by bowing
down to the gods it is evident that he
doesn't give a Frick about anything
shortly after a journalist named
kunishima and her boss visit the place
to observe the wrestlers and their
techniques as the practice gets underway
kunishima notices Jose's complete lack
of interest in the sport she attempts to
enter the ring to click better pictures
but it's reprimanded by the coach and
the senior wrestlers who inform her that
women are not allowed inside the ring
honestly it's probably for her own
safety her boss also scolds her for
potentially jeopardizing their
opportunity to cover the story elsewhere
the directors of the Nash National Sumo
Association gathered to discuss
potential promotions for wrestlers based
on their achievements during the
discussion they bring up Jose's
misconduct after his victory in a recent
tournament some members suggest
dismissing him for his behavior but the
head of the association decides to give
him a Stern warning instead meanwhile
kunishima is having a meal at work when
her boss and another colleague join her
they talk about the prestigious
reputation the end shows stable ones had
and wonder if it can regain its Fame
shortly after one of kunishima's
colleagues approaches her and taunts her
for being removed from the news
reporting team due to an alleged Affair
this provokes her anger so she slaps him
whoosh before leaving in a huff
elsewhere Shimizu approaches an upset
Jose and advises him to practice the
shiko exercise which can greatly improve
his chances of defeating his opponents
he also encourages Jose not to run away
from fights because he possesses great
strength unlike himself once again the
scene shifts to a flashback and show the
owner of the stable invites Jose to have
dinner together while they are at it He
suggests that Jose should become a sumo
wrestler emphasizing the financial
benefits honor and opportunities with
women that the sport can bring the
ladies love a big bully the latter is a
bit skeptical about the idea so he says
mean we'll think about it but later when
he notices his disabled father working
on the street he quickly decides to
accept and Show's offer and become a
sumo wrestler in the present a month has
already passed and Jose finally realizes
that substantial earnings in sumo
wrestling only come with reaching higher
ranks this realization infuriates him
and he confronts and show accusing him
of deceiving him into becoming a sumo
wrestler under false pretenses but the
latter only tells him to work harder and
improve his skills that night feeling
disheartened Jose decides to quit and
return home as he prepares to leave with
his belongings Shimizu follows him and
asks him to stay he emphasizes that Jose
is meant to be a sumo wrestler unlike
himself and that he possesses the
potential to rise to the top reflecting
on shimizu's words throughout the night
Jose ultimately decides to return to the
stable the next morning we see him alone
in the wrestling ring engaging in the
chico exercise in the next scene a brief
flashback shows a young boy named
shizuuchi standing in front of the dead
bodies of a woman and a child holding a
knife in his hand and bearing a scar on
his face elsewhere we are introduced to
ryuki a second generation sumo wrestler
who has recently been promoted to the
rank of ozeki in a press conference he
expresses his determination to surpass
his father's Legacy and head to the top
kunishima who is also present there
steps forward to ask him some questions
she inquires about the violent hazing in
many stables and the status of women in
this sport however ryuki avoids
answering these questions and abruptly
ends the interview on their way back
kunishima's boss instructs her to
respect the sport boundaries and forces
her to apologize to Anga for entering
the wrestling ring earlier kunishima
reluctantly does so and then starts
observing the wrestlers who are
practicing in the chico exercise Jose he
was tired of the boring routine suddenly
gets up and Demands a fight as a result
and show arranges a match between Jose
and a senior wrestler named Enya our
protagonist prepares him for the fight
realizing that it can either make him or
break him but sadly he loses in the
first few seconds prompting all the
seniors to mock him the evil anger takes
The Hazing to a step further by shoving
a ball of mud into Jose's mouth jokes on
him mod has many calories the same
afternoon Jose encounters Shizu oh my
God I can't say this word shizuuchi who
has now grown up to become a deadly sumo
wrestler he playfully teases him about
the scar on his face but the latter
remains unresponsive after returning to
the stable Jose receives a present from
his father along with some pictures and
other items this makes him emotional and
he starts reminiscing about all the good
times he's
family later that day the manager event
shows stable invites Jose and Danga to a
bar in an attempt to reconcile their
differences there a Hostess named nanami
approaches Jose and the two quickly
establish a friendly connection as the
evening unfolds Jose surprises everyone
with his impressive sinking voice
earning praise from everyone present
there just wait until Enya shows up in
contrast Anga embarrasses himself when
he decides to become the center of
attention in a fit of rage he strikes
Jose with a microphone sparking a fight
between them and abruptly ending the
party afterward Jose returns to the
stable only to discover that the
wrestlers have discarded his father's
gift in the trash he tries to salvage
what is left but everything appears to
have been destroyed the next morning an
Irate Jose carefully observes the
wrestlers as they practice their moves
he believes that he can emulate them
easily so in order to test it he
approaches Zenga and challenges him to a
fight the latter promptly agrees and so
the match begins Jose who's filled with
confidence use various tactics and comes
close to pushing his opponent out of
bounds however at the last moment Anga
manages to counter attack and claim
victory later on Jose receives a text
message from the bar host to snanami
inviting him to hang out oh Sumo do get
the babies babes Jesus delighted he
agrees and they spend the remainder of
the day together enjoying meals playing
games and exploring streets as the day
draws to a close she drops him off at
the stable promising to meet soon this
makes Jose very happy believing that he
has finally found the love of his life
however his Joy is short-lived when he
receives a phone call from the hospital
informing him of his father's traffic
accident panicked he immediately rushes
to the hospital and discovers his old
man lying unconscious later that night
we see Jose at a park watching video
footage of his earlier defeat by Anga
after repeatedly analyzing the footage
she gets to know that anger gained the
upper hand by utilizing the chico
exercise this finally makes him realize
that he has to master the exercise as
well so he starts practicing
relentlessly motivated by thoughts of
his hospitalized father he pushes
himself even more after a while
shizuuchi approaches him and it nailed
it approaches him and offers a canned
drink which Jose accepts before
departing the scene then shifts to
cuckoo's stable where kunishima and her
boss observe the training of other
wrestlers they witness shizuuchi
overpowering his opponent effortlessly
by using his non-dominant hand koku's
stable considers Shizu Uchi to be a true
monster who is almost Invincible
meanwhile it ends Show Stable a senior
wrestler named Enya repeatedly defeats
Jose in practice matches causing him
immense frustration Enya points out that
Jose's poor sheika skill is the main
reason for his failures according to him
Jose's sumo wrestling is like scattered
dots and he needs to develop his Chico
technique to connect those dots stick to
Sumo and singing Enya analogies are not
your thing in the afternoon Jose
Encounters shizuuchi in the same park
gazing at a tree as you Jose offers him
a cigarette but shizuchi coughs as he is
not accustomed to smoking for some
reason this makes Jose burst into
laughter on his way back to the stable a
guy asks him to deliver a gift to Anga
as he appears to have a crush on him
however instead of delivering the
package Jose opens it himself to his
surprise he finds a love letter and a
humorous pair of Underpants inside this
again makes him chuckle like a maniac
something like that moments later Jose
receives a distressing call from his
mother asking for 500 000 Yen for his
father's treatment he doesn't have that
kind of money so he devises A peculiar
plan to earn it Jose takes fetishized
photos of anga's body and secretly
records a video of him in the shower
time to make him an only flans page he
then sells it to the weirdo from earlier
in exchange for a lot of money following
this Jose decides to transfer the money
to his mother but at the same time he
receives a call from nanami who invites
him to go out so he cancels the
transaction and agrees to meet her they
then go to a sushi restaurant which
triggers Jose's memories of his parents
who used to own a similar cafe after
having their dinner together they walk
back home on their way they come across
two Turkish men who are selling ancient
stone necklaces when the Nami expresses
interest in getting one Jose reluctantly
purchased it for her unfortunately the
men noticed the large sum of cash in his
wallet and become greedy they then
pretend to take a picture with Jose and
snatch his wallet while he is distracted
by the time Jose realizes what has
happened the men have already fled the
scene this frustrates him immensely and
he regrets not sending the money for his
father's treatment later he transfers
all of his remaining savings a total of
250 000 yen to his mother's account
instructing her to use it solely for his
father's medical expenses we know she
won't though on the other hand synonymy
who arrives home pulls out Jose's wallet
from her purse revealing that she has
been plotting against him from the
beginning back at the stable and show
angrily confronts Jose as Angus photos
have gone viral all over the Internet
surprisingly Anga is not upset but
rather disappointed that Jose didn't
make him appear cooler in the photos in
the aftermath of all these events Jose
is back to his training pushing himself
to the limit in the wrestling ring and
striving to connect the so-called dots
whatever the hell that meant he also
starts practicing alone in the park in
hopes of being a better fighter one day
Jose requests a chance to fight Ang and
to his Delight he finally manages to
defeat him for the first time in
recognition of his achievement and show
bestows upon him a ring name NL creative
no exciting I guess in the next scene we
see Jose who has made it to the
tournament but his behavior remains
unchanged he lies down and starts
smoking inside the waiting area
unexpectedly Shimizu appears and greets
him it turns out that Shimizu now works
as an usher for the tournaments as it is
his only chance to stay close to sumo
wrestling something that he's always
been very passionate about kunishima
also attends the tournament and eagerly
awaits Jose's match it turns out that
Jose will be facing off against enokoshi
a wrestler from a different stable Jose
confidently steps into the ring
disregarding the tradition of bowing to
the referee and showing disrespect
towards the rules of sumo after a while
the fight commences and the two
wrestlers match each other's stride for
stride but in the end it is Jose who
emerges Victorious much to the dismay of
the rivals he then Prof forms some
erratic celebratory moves and proudly
declares his affiliation with the end
Show Stable and subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching